[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
phone is already come back player of the
year for htc for 2017. you already
remember how poor of a use of space and
money uh the ultra was just a couple
months ago well less than six months
later we get this at a very similar
price and it's the u11 so from the
outside you might not see that much of a
difference you know same shiny blue body
same thick rounded design same lack of a
headphone jack it seems at first glance
really similar because it is but as far
as packing features and specs into this
phone they cleaned up real nice so to
run right down the spec sheet you have
android 7.1.1 with the same htc software
on top it's a snapdragon 835 with the
adreno 540 four gigs of ram a 3 000
milliamp hour battery a 5.5 inch quad hd
display 64 gigs of storage expandable
via microsd and a 12 megapixel f 1.7
camera with ois now specs aren't
everything they don't tell the whole
story but here they do a pretty good job
and if we head down that spec list again
besides just of course the very
impressive numbers this phone gets a lot
of things right so with android it's
already on the latest version later than
most phones it's 7.1.1 so that's a good
sign and hopefully it gets updates plus
it has all the same features htc has
decided to add on top of android the
snapdragon 835 chipset we already know
has been awesome in other phones plus
four gigs of ram so we're expecting and
getting top-notch performance here best
in class and it's absolutely one of the
smoothest and most responsive android
phones out there right now i'm just a
little less confident with that
full-time smoothness lasting as long as
something like from a stock android
phone but i'm still very impressed with
how htc's animations just glide for the
most part they use really short simple
animations and that's what you want to
see this thing flies it's got a 3 000
milliamp hour battery not the biggest
number in the world but we're seeing
this thing outperform phones with bigger
cells and last comfortably all day
thanks to optimization and that's super
impressive considering the display and
that display is a 5.5 inch 1440p lcd
display that gets pretty bright it's
definitely not the brightest and it can
struggle outdoors so i admit that but
still high pixel density and great
colors anytime you're not outside is
going to get a thumbs up there storage
is all there 64 gigs right out the box
with a micro sd card slot and the camera
has been absolutely killing it it's a 12
megapixel sensor big wide open f 1.7
aperture and optical image stabilization
really matters and helps it a lot in low
light plus it has that same snapdragon
835 as the oneplus 5 so it's doing auto
instant hdr and this thing has been
taking some killer shots so htc can stop
right there they've already wiped the
floor with their previous phone
pretty much no reason to buy the ultra
anymore but i haven't even gotten to the
headlining feature of this phone so the
main major headlining feature of the u11
is a custom shortcut that's mapped to
squeezing the phone it's called edge
sense so this is for real so instead of
a custom button like an extra key or an
edge display feature or anything like
that htc has crammed pressure sensors
into the size of this phone specifically
in the lower half on both sides so you
can squeeze the phone to launch any app
of your choice it can be the assistant
or the camera or your instagram or
whatever you want really or you can have
squeeze to take screenshots or toggle
the flashlight or instantly start a
voice recording or turn wi-fi hotspot on
so it's completely custom it can do a
lot of things the question is
squeezing it is that a gimmick or is
that legit well i think that all really
will depend on how your hands
wrap around this phone and how natural
you think it feels to just squeeze the
phone in the middle of using it it can
be kind of a weird thing depending on
the way you hold the phone to squeeze it
to launch something maybe a bit
unnatural the phone doesn't flex at all
it's metal but htc actually does let you
calibrate how hard you want to have to
squeeze before it activates edge sense
so there's 10 different pressure levels
so naturally naturally you'd think you'd
want to set it as low as possible
so you don't have to grip the phone
super hard just to launch something but
the thing is if you set the squeeze
value too low you can actually
accidentally start triggering it when
you're just picking up the phone off a
table i had it happen to me a couple of
times it can be too sensitive or even
sometimes when you're just pulling out
your pocket it's not the end of the
world but it still does launch that
stuff accidentally but if you set the
squeeze level too high then you need
like a two-handed vice grip on the phone
just to squeeze it hard enough to
trigger it and that's not natural at all
so you kind of have to have it somewhere
in the middle got to make sure you
calibrate it right i found it best at
around level four or five and i also
tried a bunch of different grips not
everyone holds the phone the same way
but basically if you do squeeze just one
side of the phone that will activate it
too so you can squeeze one side or the
other on the lower half that'll be fine
so while it was definitely weird at
first for me to squeeze the phone
instead of just pressing a custom button
or launching my app it did pretty
quickly get pretty easy with that
mid-level squeeze pressure the more i
got into it the more i got used to it
you can enable advanced mode which lets
you set different shortcuts to a quick
squeeze versus a long squeeze kind of
like a single press versus a long press
if it was a button and you can really
dig down and customize a whole lot of
functionality just in squeezing this
phone so if you're into it this phone is
already a pretty complete package and
then you add the squeeze feature on top
of all of that and it becomes really
interesting i would buy and use this
phone if i was more of a fan of htc
software but i'm not a more of a pure
android person but this it's not perfect
this phone is definitely not perfect
there's still no headphone jack that's
still a poor use of space it's still
super shiny and very reflective and i
think the anodized matte blue look
around the edges would have looked way
hotter for the entire back of the phone
but we still have this mirror and the
fingerprint reader is still annoyingly
small and the bezels are still
annoyingly big so it's not perfect but
this is a way better phone than six
months ago and i think they have the
right idea trying to do something new
with interaction but still trying to
make it feel somewhat natural kind of
just in the grip of while you're using
the phone every day but that'll of
course all depend on whether you guys
buy this phone or not and what you guys
think so let me know what you think is
this the whole squeeze thing a gimmick
will it be dead in a year or is it the
next big thing is it gonna catch on your
guess is as good as mine but feel free
to leave a comment below and then come
back to it in a year and see if you're
right or not so that's pretty much it
thank you for watching and i'll talk to
you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]